welcome back to glamour unfiltered with
me Josh Smith and today we are joined by
one of the most inspiring 19 year olds
on the entire planets yasha he D thank
you have been busy
you starting blackish you've gone to
star in brownish you SAP your own
initiative called 18 x 18 young photos
you spoke about gun crime and on top of
all of that you're now starting this
incredible film the Sun is also a star
yeah which is an incredibly inspiring
story about Natasha who goes through New
York City in one day and she tries to
make sure her family can stay in America
and not face deportation and at the same
time she also picks up a lot
yeah-ha-ha how did she do it quite the
multitasker right the multi-touch I
think because we are talking about
deportation we're talking about
immigration it was really important to
us that it never felt like some aside to
a love story to like a young adult
romance one of the things that really
spoke to me as well as it's a very
important message about accepting others
and how we also other people at the same
time as a society we're still very prone
to other people who we are unaware of
we're not educators back right and
amazingly like you have this jewel
heritage you're half Iranian you're half
black America and so can you ever
remember a time where you felt
segregated against or if you felt others
got a daily basis there are moments and
reminders of not being in mainstream one
thing that made me really relate to to
the novel and then to the movie it was
this idea of like I know what it's like
to come from a country or have family
that's where I come from that's on the
travel ban list there are so many
moments whether it's my hair whether
it's comments on people preferring it
straight whether it's comments on Iran
whether it's
on blackness and like what people expect
of a black human a reminder that almost
motivates me is knowing that I've barely
gone through the worst of it and knowing
that there's so many people who have to
endure so much more on a regular basis
and I've been protected by people who've
intentionally put me an inclusive
environment and I think that's what's
made me so motivated to be able to speak
out not only on behalf of myself but my
entire community I think what's so
empowering for is for showing people
that you can have a voice and having a
voice is such an empowering thing
because sitting here I think you're such
a competent incredible human being and
I've watched so many inches from Hugh
preparation for this I'm just like yes
hey you say I'm just like go for it but
what kind of struggles and what kind of
obstacles have you had to overcome to
have your own voice and feel empowered
about your own voice the one thing that
I've realized especially now being a
teenager going into being a proper young
adults to being an adult is that I'm
much more comfortable sometimes talking
about politics that I am standing up for
myself and and so there are those
moments in which while I feel completely
confident standing up for others there's
some trepidation if it comes down to
what I personally want or need but there
are those moments of definitely not
feeling as confident as people may
initially think and you know I think my
other passion for helping people gain
equity is what motivates this other
thing but so many times I'm like oh well
maybe it's not that big of a deal and so
that's something I'm actively working on
because I don't know if you can really
truly advocate for others to your best
ability if you don't have the ability to
advocate for yourself what would someone
say to you that really grinds you guys
the adult efficacious of young women
especially young women of color for
example there was one moment in which I
was talking to an editor of a magazine
and you know this magazine they're
supposed to represent you know like
women in Hollywood and it was really
important to me that there was diversity
and who they chose to celebrate I was
like we're at a particularly wonderful
time in television and although we're
not perfect there are lots of people
doing their very best representing
people that have never been seen on TV
before
so I go and show up and the three
actresses that are there who are
wonderful people by the way look like
triplets like they have possibly chosen
like the most kind of homogeneous group
possible and I have nothing against
those those humans as individuals
because they're wonderful actresses who
are definitely deserving of their
position but as a magazine they
genuinely felt like nothing was wrong
but genuinely didn't understand what was
happening or why this could be a problem
or what the implications were of
overlooking people who have done
incredible shifting work on television
and not celebrating that I was like
it'll be unfair to the communities that
I am from for me to be the sole
representative of this it becomes
reductive if I am the only person at the
table if you have multiple people have
one experience and I'm the only person
who's representing perpetually I mean to
your point representing the other and so
I chose to opt out of the roundtable and
long story short the editor of the
magazine comes up to me and is asking
why and so she's talking to me as though
I'm an adult but the issue is she's not
hearing my response and not respecting
it and so there's that situation of so
you want to have this conversation with
me as an adult but you're not giving me
the mutual respect to hear my response
of saying I don't want to participate I
think a lot people can be very deaf at
times to the things that going around
them like as a gay man myself like
living in 21st century London England
where we've seen as like a very work
generation right and people can say
really stupid dismissive things
sometimes when they say oh homophobe
doesn't exist anymore
racism doesn't exist anymore and people
say and this is what this movie raises
so was that people can be so deaf to
other people's experiences and not have
their mind open to those things yes it's
so incredible you can sit here and say
these things as an empowered 19 year old
it's just incredible it's really
important to me because you know I do
recognize the particular privilege I
haven't having this platform and being
given opportunities where I get to do
work that I absolutely love it's
important that I use the platform to not
only advocate for my obvious communities
but my generation at large because
you're absolutely right and what we know
of especially Generation Z is I think we
take it more identity
korie's in previous generations which
means it's extremely important to
advocate for the intersections of of you
know I think the conversation around and
I'm constantly educating myself to the
best of my ability about things that
weren't necessarily initially in my
purview of whether it's being neuro
atypical what does it mean to actually
discuss having a disability and how do
you discuss that respectfully this is
exactly what we need this kind of stuff
isn't really what we need I think also
really amazing thing that this film
raises as well yes black beauty and how
it's been so marginalized for such a
long period of time and now we're
finally living in a time where it's
being representative in a more
empowering way that it's more available
in more mass shops for instance right
how is your relationship with Beauty
change do you think how have you learnt
we'll come up one with your own skin I
didn't watch much TV or I didn't watch
many movies growing up I was very I
think my parents were very selective and
and not in a sort of like hyper guarding
me kind of way but it just in being
intentional about what's placed in front
of me and knowing that they're greater
implications to only seeing Cinderella
but it wasn't really until I hit the age
of like maybe 13 when I was in middle
school that was when jobs started
requesting my hair straight for example
or even simple things like I was on my
school's debate team and you know I was
at a school where the entire debate team
were young women of color and here we
are with googly different hair textures
completely different ethnicities but
we're all straightening our hair before
the debate largely because we just
thought it was more professional than
than the hair that we were born with but
that was also what we were kind of told
and what was assumed was like if you
want to be taken seriously this is how
you look and even starting blackish I
mean it's a incredibly supportive
environment but to be 13 and to have to
have makeup on for HD cameras and lights
there was a moment in time where I went
from not really caring if I had lip
gloss on or not or only really doing
makeup when I felt like it was fun to
feeling like it's what I needed to look
ready I think I'm at a much more
comfortable place now or I feel free to
explore and there definitely times in
which I'm insecure whether it's just
about like we're in an industry where I
spend like to be honest a lot of time
looking at myself you know like I just
such a wind expand
site which people don't realize uh-huh
and I think it breeds unintentional just
self centric behavior oftentimes you
hear like oh Hollywood they're so
self-absorbed this or that that hasn't
been my experience I've met so many
giving people but I think just like
their symptoms to like literally staring
at yourself in the mirror or literally
seeing articles about whether people did
or didn't like your outfit did or didn't
like your face one day and so those are
definitely things that I work through on
it like a daily basis but I have a much
stronger foundation we are like you said
at a better time in which we are seeing
more people be very intentional about
representing especially blackness in
particular knowing that it's not
monolithic I am NOT the sole
representative you know we span so many
beautiful shades we spend so many
different identities and cultures and
experiences there are so many
representations and I'm really grateful
to have that because I think it serves
as a reeducation for some and they're
going to be somewhere this is the world
that they're born into